Charles darwin,
the miles managed son of a physician was once described as the most dangerous
man in England.
In fact,
many people would consider them to be the agents of the devil himself come to
sow seeds of corruption.
Among the faithful is ideas struck like a storm at the very foundation of
society turning conventional religious thought on its hat.
Yes.
Just a few years earlier,
he had his sights set on becoming a priest and devoting his life to God.
In this week's biographics we investigate the life and the ideas of Charles
Darwin.
Charles Robert Darwin was born in Shrewsbury,
England on February the 12th 1809 his father Robert was a doctor and his mother
Susanna.
It was the daughter of the famous potteries owner,
Josiah Wedgwood jars.
His grandfather was Erasmus Darwin,
well known in his time as a scientist with unusual ideas.
He wrote on a range of subjects including travel by air.
We're exploring by submarine and evolution.
Despite his learned father and eminence grandfather Charles,
his early years were not outstanding.
He attended Shrewsbury School were the main lessons where in the classics such
as Latin,
his school masters and his father considered them to be a boy of very ordinary
intelligence despite his apparent lack of promise.
Charles showed a great interest in learning boss rather than studying Greek and
in like most of the students of the time,
he was taken with the English poetry of William Wordsworth and Lord Byron.
When Charles was a teenager,
science began to captivate them so much so in fact that he had his brother
Erasmus build a chemistry lab in a garden shed in 1825 Charles attended
Edinburgh medical school in Scotland,
but he was not a good medical students.
He found the lectures dull.
Ma'Ams had to leave the operating theater because he could not stand the horrors
of surgery.
One thing he did enjoy though was the study of taxidermy,
which he learns from a format African slave named John Edmondson.
During his second year in Scotland,
Darwin joins the Plinian Society,
a club for naturalists.
He was taken with that intellectual debates,
which exposed him to ideas of how man was created,
not buying guns,
but by gradual changes in form.
Over time,
these ideas had been espoused by Charles,
his own grandfather,
Erasmus,
Darwin,
while of the university,
Darwin Matters.
Ecologist named Robert Grants,
and the two became close friends.
Grant has been credited with being the first person to interest Darwin in the
theory of evolution.
At this time,
Charles began collecting fossils since learning more about animal life,
so the great disappointment of his father Charles quit medical school in 1827 he
joined his uncle Josiah Wedgwood,
the second for a trip to Paris as see vacations his father still fretting over
his son dropping out of medical school,
made plans for Charles to study for the clergy enrolling him.
It's Christ's College Cambridge University.
Despite the evolutionary ideas that had been filling his mind's during his time
at Edinburgh,
Charles still held to a belief in creation.
Later he rose.
I did not then in the least doubt,
these strict and literal truth of every word in the Bible.
During the summer before his studies began,
Charles fell in love with a girl by the name of Fanny Oh in the sister of one of
his friends.
They spend long hours talking,
riding horses and playing cards.
Darwin's theological studies at Cambridge began towards the end of 1827 but
rather than getting immersed in the Bible,
he developed a fondness for collecting beetles.
He attended lectures on botany given bunny the reverend John Stevens Henslow.
Darwin saw this as a possible career path and he pursued his studies with
enthusiasm.
By ACR 29 it became clear that Darwin had no interest in joining the clergy.
He spent that spring break with the Reverend Frederick hope and noted
entomologist.
Here's obsession with the study of Beatle Song,
no time for his budding romance with fanny,
and they broke up that following spring.
Despite his general lack of interest in his clerical studies,
Darwin past his finals exam in January,
1831 basing 10 fitness class finished with school.
He was all set to become a countryside clergy or the edge one with a deep
scientific interest,
but reverend Hansley who had become something of a mentor to Charles suggested
that he should see some of the world's before he settled down to his posting to
oh in decided to take a trip to the Canary Islands off the coast of Spain.
He plans to go with his friend's Momma do Ramsey.
They intended to study the geological formations on the islands,
but before they could set sail,
Ramsey died.
Suddenly Darwin was stricken with grief and could not travel to the islands.
A few weeks later he received a letter from reverend Henslow informing him that
there was an opening on a ship that may interest him.
The HMS Beagle,
which was bound for South America.
The bagel was being repaired as one of several ships scheduled to map South
America.
Robert Fitzroy,
the captain of the Beagle,
recognize that the long voyage would require for a variety of men to be on board
for companionship.
He was keen to have a scholar gentlemen who could help describe the areas that
were being charted as well as to relieve the TDM between ports of call.
When the opening presented itself,
Darwin was keen to fill the spot.
However,
his father Roberts refused to give his adult son permission to embark on a
voyage.
Robert's continued to believe that Charles,
his interest in science was merely a passing fad and that the young man remained
adrift.
It was left to Charles,
his uncle Joe Cya to step in and to persuade his brother to give permission for
his son to join the expedition.
Charles then hastened to London's and meet with caps in Fitzroy in the hope of
that the offer was still available.
He was in luck with plans for a September departure,
gradually moved back the ship.
Finally set sail on Tuesday,
December the 27th 1831 Darwin found himself in a small cabin that was nine feet
by 11 feet long and only five feet high.
Part of his cabin was taken over by one of the masts rising through it from the
start.
He was seasick.
A condition that remained over the next five years.
On January the 16th 1830 do the big or stopped at Cape Verde off the western
coast of Africa,
her Darwin founder band of fossil shells,
45 feet above sea level.
How he wondered the fossils rise so high.
After 23 days,
the crew was set out for Brazil arriving in the port city of Salvador at the end
of February,
1832 are up to spring.
The big old traveled along the Brazilian coast stopping in many ports at each
stop.
Darwin took long hikes.
Collecting many specimens he could likes is a huge number of specimens which he
carefully catalogs and protected on board Fitzroy and the crew.
They consider this work worthless and is growing collection a load of junk,
but to trials,
they were precious scientific discoveries.
Every few months.
He arranged for a shipments to be sent back to reverend Henslow in Cambridge for
safekeeping from Brazil,
the Beagle at sales to Patagonia,
a large region of South America that is now Argentina.
They're Darwin collected fossils,
bits of bone and feathers that he had never before encountered.
He struggles to accurately record their features in the hopes that more
experienced naturalists could later help to identify them from Patagonia.
The Beagle went further to Tierra del Fuego.
It was here that Darwin encountered native people who still dwells in the jungle
and were considered to be at savages by the Europeans.
By march of 1833 the crew of the Beagle began mapping the Falkland Islands,
which the British had claimed from Argentina actress months earlier,
fascinated by the burdens animal fossils found that Darwin spent his time
comparing the specimens with everything he had collected to date the work that
Darwin was immersed in.
It was becoming so exhaustive that he recognized the need to take on a servant.
He wrote home to his father asking for the money to hire someone.
When permission came back,
he asked the ships odd job,
man,
sims coverings,
and to take on the role.
Meanwhile,
the letters that Charles had been sending back to reverend tens low were being
read aloud to the Philosophical Society of Cambridge.
This owns Darwin and early reputation as an excellent naturalist and observer on
Darwin's 25th birthday.
Captain Fitzroy names the highest mountain in the Tierra del Fuego region
mounts.
Darwin in Charles is on that by 1834 the ship had sailed round Cape Horn at the
southern tip of South America and crossed from the Atlantic to the Pacific
Ocean.
During the summer,
Darwin became quite ill.
He was deemed too sick to continue the voyage and spent four frustrating months
in Tierra del Fuego.
Recovering.
Historians believe that he had chagas disease,
which is a form of sniffing sickness.
Though in returns of the Beagle in November of 1834 the ship rounded Cape Horn
and sales up self,
America's west coast.
On February the 20th 1835 a great earthquake shook the region and during the
boards of Concepcion in Chile,
Darwin saw the appalling damage.
He also noted that the rocks around the harbor had been lifted almost a meter by
the earth's movements,
shellfish and seaweeds,
which were normally near the water.
We're now high and dry,
so could such catastrophic changes in the surroundings.
The linked to changes in parts and animals is what he wondered.
The Beagle now left South America and set sail across the Pacific Ocean almost a
thousand kilometers from the mainland.
It angered does a group of about 13 small rocky islands on the equator.
These were of course the Galapagos Islands.
Darwin was immediately struck by the strange nature of the birds,
reptiles and others that he found that they seemed unique to these islands.
Yet they had many similarities to species founds on these South American
mainland's stranger still each island had its own kind of animal.
One example was the giant tortoises winning more than 200 kilograms,
which the ship's crew right around like horses.
The local people could tell which island did tortoise came from by the shape of
its shell.
Darwin was especially intrigued by one group of birds,
the finches,
they were mostly small and drab,
Brown in color,
but each species had a slightly different size and shape of beak allowing it to
tackle a certain kind of food.
Darwin noted in his notebook,
one made really fancy that from an original paucity of birds in the archipelago,
one species had been taken and modified for different ends.
The idea of evolution,
but it was beginning to take root.
The bagel sailed on across the Pacific to Tahiti where Darwin fell in love with
the misty peaks,
tropical plants,
colorful animals,
and these simple natural lifestyle of the local people.
The journey continued on towards New Zealand and then Australia.
He was shocked at the terrible living conditions of the local people and the own
lands.
They were ruled over and made slaves by European settlers.
This seemed to support his observations from the animal world that the stronger
always took over from the week.
Okay.
The Beagle returned to Fallon,
the thing balloons on the 2nd of October,
1836.
They had been away for five years.
Darwin's spend the next few years organizing and cataloging his vast collection
of plants,
animals,
rocks,
and fossils.
By the summer of 1838,
Darwin felt bold enough to share his radical ideas with this father.
We took them in his straight for the last several months.
Charles had struck up a close relationship with his cousin,
Nema Wedgewood.
However,
when he brought up the subject of marrying and uh,
his father warned that she came from a very strict family,
Amma would never consider Darwin's theories as anything but heresy deeply in
love.
Though Darwin ignored his father's advice to curtail the romance.
He mentioned some of his notions regarding religion in nature to Emma.
It was surprisingly understanding Darwin juggled numerous tasks from writing
books to studying more fossils to watching apes and hangs at the London Zoo as
he works.
He also continued his relationship with Emma.
You proposed to her on November the 11th,
1838.
The proposal was well received by both sides of family.
Arrangements were made for Darwin to receive a handsome annual sum of money from
his father.
This would allow the couple to live while Darwin continued retaining Covington
services.
Since research on his theory of evolution was still incomplete,
jaws and Emma were married on January the 29th,
1839 the couple of settles into her home in London,
which was already filled with scientific material.
Shortly thereafter,
Covington left Darwin's employment to make his own fortune.
He was replaced by a man named Joseph Pass Layer.
During the spring of 1839 Darwin carried out research.
I'm crossbreeding.
He asked various experts,
including farmers questions about how they crossbred their animals.
He filled page off the page with his correspondences in May.
The multivolume collection he wrote with Captain Fitzroy narrative of the
surveying voyages of the HMS Beagle was finally released to the public.
This celebration of the beagles voyage,
it became a best seller.
Charles was now a respected scientist and author and as a member of the royal
society
during the 1814 and 1850 stolen,
continued his research and writing.
In 1842 he wrote a geology book entitled the structure and distribution of coral
reefs with two more geology books following in the next few years.
As time went on,
his health began to fail.
He could only do a few hours of work each day.
His illness,
it was never identifies,
but it could have been the after effects of his tropical sickness.
While on his five year voyage.
Despite his illness,
he continued his research.
And so the idea of evolution,
he was becoming more and more convinced that species we're not fixed and
immutable.
He had written a short version of his ideas in 1842 but decided to collect every
scrap of information he could and write a lengthy book with masses of evidence
for his theory.
For many years,
Darwin was reluctance to publish his ideas on evolution by natural selection.
It's meant that animals and plants evolved naturally.
He now believed that God have not created them.
However,
most people at the time,
including many scientists,
still believed in the truth of the Bible.
He knew that speaking out against the accepted teachings of the Bible was set
into a fence and cause a storm of protest.
Darwin may have never finished his work on evolution,
but for a letter which arrived at his home in Kent in June,
1885 from Malaysia,
it was from another English naturalist,
Alfred Wallace.
Wallace knew that Darwin was interested in evolution.
So with his letter he sent his summary of the theory.
Darwin was amazed.
All of the work he had so patiently done over the last 20 years was neatly
described by Wallace as a scientific meeting at the nae and society in London.
The works of both Wallace and Darwin were read outs in July of 1858 after that
one,
it's agreed the Darwin who had gathered far more evidence to support their joint
theory should carry on with the idea while he stood aside to Olin did say weekly
finishing his great book.
It was published on the 24th of November,
1859 and it was called the origin of species.
The publisher of Darwin's book,
John Mary Reddit's before printing it and realized a great outcry would follow.
As a result,
he only printed 1,250 copies.
These sold out almost at once and a second edition was quickly produced.
They've all,
they were indeed outraged.
Darwin one's denying the truth that was in the Bible scientists and lined up to
have their say with many criticizing Darwin.
One clergymen cools,
the quiet,
mild mannered Darwin,
the most dangerous man in England,
but others quickly recognized the good signs in Darwin as ideas and to the vast
amount of evidence which supported them.
The biologist Thomas Huxley spoke for him in England while professor of botany
at Harvard University,
a sick gray it.
It's great supporter in North America.
Darwin himself stayed in camps and took little part in the arguments.
So now the question arises,
well,
what did Darwin actually postulate in his famous book?
Well,
the origin of species by means of natural selection or the preservation of
favored races in the struggle for life is a long but very readable book.
It begins by looking at variation under domestication,
including pigeons,
horses,
and garden flowers.
Then it covers variation in nature and the problems of identifying a species.
It shows how the offspring of parents are all similar but slightly different.
These slight differences might give an individual a better chance of succeeding
and staying alive.
Laser chapters deal with animal instincts,
fossils,
and the geographical and manner of animals and plants from mice to elephants.
Yet.
He never explains the origin of any one species.
As I mentioned,
the origin of species,
sharks and angered many people including Darwin own family to accept the theory
of evolution meant accepting that the accounts in the Bible of creation of
animal and plant species could not be true.
Many scientists,
they simply struggles to believe in both gradually.
However,
the theory of evolution by natural selection gained grounds and most scientists
came to believe that Darwin was right Darwin,
he did not retire after the origin of species was published.
He kept up his studies and researchers and carried on with his experiments and
nature observations.
In 1871 he published descent of man then selection in relation to sex.
In this work,
he concluded that humans are not the result of special creation,
but that they have evolved along with other animals.
Their ancestors could indeed be traced back far into prehistory.
In the 1870s Darwin's health improved and in 1877 he was awarded a special
degree by Cambridge University.
He continued to write books about insect eating plants,
how plants grow and move,
and how they encourage decay and enrich the soil with Descente huge success as
well.
Darwin divided his time between revising the two works.
In April of 1874 he completed work on descents second edition.
This was the last time he wrote about evolution between projects and illnesses.
Darwin continued to refine his work a decade after its first publication.
The fifth edition of origin was released.
The sixth edition published in 1871 use the word evolution for the first time
after a mild heart attack in December of 1881 Charles Darwin died several months
later,
peacefully at down house.
His home of Nettie 50 years.
He was 73 years old.
By this time,
the storm of protests over the origin of species had died away and Darwin had
become a national figure and one of the best known scientific names of all time.
It was laid to rest at Westminster Abbey London next to the Great Isaac Newton.
The funeral was attended by dozens of politicians,
inventors,
explorers,
scientists,
and artists along with members of the scientific communities of many countries.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.